alors je ne sais pas pour vous mais nous
sommes comme on veut ou publié chez
michel lafon un livre qui s'appelle sans
compromis conversation avec sylvie
tellier miss france 2002 bonsoir s'il
aimerait tous avoir alors elle est bien
s'il vit dans la tête alors c'est sale
c'est la seule que jamais posé nue quand
même hein on va permettre ça x comment
ça se fait quand on était miss france on
pose nue c'est un petit plus anciens
devient de plus en plus ses malédictions
web d'un siècle
c'est quand même connu j'ai pas eu
besoin de deux ans mais ma culotte et
elle en est revenue voilà voilà
m
c'est pas trop tard peut-être peut-être
cette enquête est une proposition d'un
journal pour poser mais je n'y arrive
pas il vous est à tu vois ma règle son
chapeau les impôts sont les fesses ça
donne envie de claquer trois euros
bénéficiant à la fois laetitia bléger à
poil sérieux mais c'est pas le problème
c'est pas le projet n'avait pas été bien
s'arrêter miss france ouais comme j'aime
bien c'est donc les boys en entrevue
elle aurait posé dans l'expansion il va
pas eu de soucis aux est par exemple
dans votre beauté dans les mains ça
n'aurait pas été la même que nos tests
en tous les cas elle est interdite de
des sharp pendant six mois les remplacer
par miss bourdon céline a changé après
le vin d'alsace et vins de bourgogne
bon vous savez que laëtitia complètement
manipulée par cette jeune et vous savez
par les chevaliers mais c'est une secte
tiens là dessus ce que j'ai dit avec les
jeux complètement soumise
je crois qu'il vous fait marcher la
passion non y va non usage j'espère
qu'il s'en est rendue point je m'en suis
rendu compte surtout comme c'est quand
je m'en suis rendu compte quand elle a
dit grâce à geneviève un coup médiatique
en 48 heures à raison à la raison allait
aller 1 1
je préfère être dans ma pompe dans le
ciel oui bah on va voir manille à la
botte le même look que moi non plus avec
miss france
[Musique]
je vais vous souhaiter un très bel été
de dire que laetitia joindre remercions
de cette chance incroyable que nous
allons faire de devenir célèbre
c'est geneviève sognac j'aime bien
j'aime bien
jeumont
ouais
j'aime bien
john bell
notons bien jeune mais je suis désolé
j'aime bien et que j'aime bien et je
suis désolé l'engin
l'eau
qu'ont en hommage plein fouet
c'est sûr
laurent non non c'est miss beau laurent
laurent aller dans les samedis c'est
miss bourgogne qui fait d'un terrine
laurent elle n'a pas fait du porno miss
bourgogne a fait déplacer maintenant
c'est fait on est dans le noir je crois
que c'est moi et je crois que chez moi
jusqu'à chasser civis est porno avec
miss bourgogne non666
elle étudie alors la cassette porno avec
miss bourgogne tu l'as vu toi quand elle
rentre dans sa coquille magnétique et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater le une
altitude
abonnez vous il m'était impossible eux